i probably would not have jumped to
another network i'm pretty loyal
um
you're the most loyal that's why you're
sitting here today with me well
yeah it's just
uh
you know i sleep well at night i don't
have you know i would read all these
stories how
um
i came back and demanded 150 million
dollars plus i wanted the show back and
the network had to give it to me
based on one
this is so cathartic for me i hope it's
doing something for you all right okay
so then
have you been sitting on all these
emotions oh you have no idea how many
times i've gotten in fights
and i've talked to people that we both
know and go what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that's not the way it
happened i know but why the [ __ ] doesn't
jay defend himself you know why because
nobody cares except for him he cares
what i mean is what is not fair it's the
end of the day
pull the numbers okay here we are 10
years after it's all over
okay the tonight show was number one
through the whole tenure except for the
first 18 months when letterman had it
uh and that's the only number that
counts no you mean when conan no no
when when when letterman went to cbs he
was beating
that's on the first show first 18 months
and then we got it back and and never
lost it and and we wanted every
demographic group and all that kind of
stuff and my attitude was letterman will
get the cool kids and the critics
and i'll take the popular vote
and that's pretty much how it worked out
well for everybody and you engineered
that that's not by accident no that's
not by accident you engineer that
because you could have the cool kids i
talked to you backstage well the thing
you have a different sensibility in real
life than you do on youtube we did win
we we did win all the demographic you
know i would always hear from well
letterman wins the 18 to
no we didn't we won that too we we won
that we we always did pretty well
so let me let me just follow this story
because this is this is my therapy
session okay for you on behalf of you
all right okay
so so
then uh
what happens happens you're doing your
10 o'clock show in prime time uh conan
moves into the tonight show and for all
intents and purposes the tonight show
is not doing great
right and somehow this is my fault you
know
so you get a call
and they ask you before they ask conan
because you're still on the network
would you be willing to go back and do a
half hour show at 11 35 right right
right am i correct yeah with just the
monologue and all that just the
monologue of maybe one gaster but i said
run it past kona
before he said yes he said run it past
conan now
conan has not
been doing well on the tonight show
the truth of the matter is
they call gavin and they say
we'll do the show at 11 30
we want leno to do it at 11 35 and you
go on a 1205 and you still have the
tonight show you can do exactly what
you're doing but now we're giving you
the opening act that has worked
for the last 20 years 15 years whatever
whatever it was
it's that
hissy fit that i didn't understand and
then the narrative this is what bothers
me about you jay you didn't change the
narrative the narrative was he retired
and now he's taking my job he was still
offered the tonight show they wanted to
reprogram it back you said you go first
you were forced to
i don't know what you did wrong i don't
know what could be interpreted as you're
doing wrong but there was this all this
hoopla and maybe i live in a bubble
where that's not the way people thought
you didn't deserve that negative one it
sounds like it's only because one person
was vocal so therefore well my favorite
thing was
when they came to me i said you know
we've been number one for 14 years
and i'm i'm not going to say which
executive said we want what's above
number one
i said well
i said i'm not
i don't know what oh you gotta i don't
know what to tell you
you know i mean i just thought that was
so funny and they realized how stupid
that sounded i said what what they were
looking for was i don't know
more pizzazz what you know when you do a
show like the tonight show at 11 30 you
can't be outrageous no every night no
it's like sam can it's an outrageous
hilarious comedy but if you do it every
night you can't be outrageous every
night so you have to bring it down a
step and you've got to become now okay
people lying in bed or watching late at
night it's got to be a bit more relaxed
it's got to have a different pacing to
it yeah
and
the idea was do you want to be the cool
guy and lose the tonight show after a
few months or do you want to keep it
going well the idea it's a business
you've been hired to do a job so you
have to act and perform a certain way to
do that job but that didn't bother you
that didn't bother you the hoopla of you
the the the the
the thought or what people were talking
about about you taking something away
from conan well i mean
i would hear it all the time on stern
and all that and and uh you know i
argued with him about that you actually
called me once after oh i argued with
him i always heard it on stern too every
time when i was on but i mean you know
the i stole jaywalking from howard no it
i mean if anybody stole it we all stole
it from steve allen who did it
man on the street stuff you know so
what do you do it
because the lower you yell they're going
to yell even louder but you said you
didn't want to say that you were
retiring that you were being forced to
retire because of the thousand paper
cuts at this point when they're saying
you move back on and you're taking it
away from conan
is that a thousand is that a thousand
paper what can they say
i didn't take it back why wouldn't you
say they called i you know i i told them
to call you i don't they're offering me
this i would be called a liar until the
be told that wasn't true you know
if you let if you if they say it's a
one-day story if you then react you now
have a three or four day story how many
times you've seen this someone's accused
of something and they go no
no comment well how about no comment
it's not a one-day story all these two
stories of you and letterman and you and
conan became books became tv shows
became many that's not a one-day story
no but what i mean is it just to the
general public is just
it's like rich guys throwing silver
dollars in the ocean to see who has the
most money it's like
you know just
nobody cares
i was involved in it and i didn't care
guys talk yourselves out howard have a
good time trash me all you want fine you
know i used to love it when he would go
on letterman i'm going to trash leno
tonight and then i'd i checked the
ratings the next day and we would beat
howard
you know and i would say oh okay that
was good i mean i don't i don't hate
howard it's what he does and that's fine
but he know i didn't steal john melendez
from howard
john melendez was doing uh i'm asleep
i'm a celebrity get me out of here okay
so he did that whole show when he left
that show
he came to us
and somebody suggested it might be fun
to have them and i said well let's see
if there's any problem here okay he was
making 35 000 a year doing howard stern
i paid him half a million a year who
wouldn't take that raise
who wouldn't take that job plus he had
had another whole tv series in between
so he wasn't even on howard but you know
i would hear this thing about oh leno
came in and took him and then all the
you know the minions would call you and
berate you
[Music]
bye